[Music]
why did you help me in the bar that
night was I supposed to do I had to get
involved is what it is I guess you know
it's almost like you were happy for the
excuse
for those people I don't know I think
you're hiding something
[Music]
they killed everybody that I've ever
cared about
how do you think that feels
trusty pinion a friend of mine betrayed
me
I think about the Punisher every night
he thinks that he has the right to judge
me on him to feel what I felt we have a
mutual Queen's my kiss on the girl so
snack
and he has an arc
Frank people are gonna die I'm gonna end
it
what a family chance here I'm not the
one who dies kid
I'm the one who does the killing
got some serious issues
let me be what I'm meant to be
[Music]
give me some meat
I'll need some money not suspicious at
all
hey everybody is Charlie we got a new
Punisher Season 2 footage to break down
it gives you a pretty good sense for the
arc of the season what the big conflicts
are going to be and if you haven't
spotted any of the marketing that
they've been laying down or the teasers
they are really hyping up comic book
jigsaw vs. comic book Punisher so
there's a lot of Punisher warzone Easter
eggs in here you may remember if you're
Big Punisher comic book fan but we'll do
a new round of that IMAX ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the trailer on the video
they haven't said how many episodes that
are going to be so I'm assuming there's
gonna be 13 but it's premiering next
week so just a big reminder about that
for those of you asking where this takes
place in the timeline the producers
confirm that it does take place after
the snap in Avengers infinity war but
before the events of Avengers endgame
the only Marvel TV series that I know of
that will take place after avengers
endgame is going to be agents of shield
season 6 later this summer they did say
though that they're not going to talk
about any of the things that happened
during the snap the show will not
address that but it did happen so you
just have to imagine the Frank Castle
was traveling around the United States
while everybody had been snapped away so
I think it's pretty easy to assume that
he was not snapped and was just off by
himself not around a lot of people
otherwise he'd probably be freaking out
too like what the hell people are
disappearing into ash all over the place
it would be funny to see Punisher share
an actual scene with Thanos if he didn't
read the recent Thanos comic book is set
many millions of years in the future of
the universe after pretty much
everything has died Thanos is one of the
last living beings he lives inside the
skull of Galactus and his Herald so to
speak bit of an easter egg for Silver
Surfer is actually the Punisher who has
been turned into the new Ghost Rider so
this is the Frank Castle Punisher Ghost
Rider that's living with him really cool
story but obviously doesn't have
anything to do with Punisher season 2
but Punisher has shared scenes with
Thanos before love the way they opened
the trailer with some classic Patrick
Swayze Roadhouse Roadhouse like
Punishers
been traveling across the United States
trying to not be violent I think I said
it in previous videos but the way the
producers explain it is that he's trying
to get a look at the United States I
just travel around to all these
different places that he spent a lot of
time defending being in the military
fighting in wars but he's never actually
taken the time to see some of these like
really cool landmarks and places so he's
actually trying to enjoy himself taking
a little break from being the Punisher
but Amy Bendix here the character these
rescuing in the bar is sort of his call
to action like what am I gonna do not
get involved so if you didn't know Amy
Bendix is a comic book character she
debuted and Punisher war zone number 24
in 1994 and is essentially kind of the
same basic character relatively
defenseless young girl that Punisher
helps save but she only appeared in four
issues so she's not like a really big
comic-book character or anything like
that so just assume that the Punisher TV
show is doing their own thing with her
she's the lovable scamp that he takes
under her wing because it sounds like
they don't really tell you in the
trailer that she's running from a group
of people the Reiser led by the john
pilgrim villain character he's one of
the main villains of season two or
there's a group of people she's running
from they just hire him as a mercenary
there was all this talk of him having
this really religious background like
he's wearing ministers clothing so I
don't know if he's a minister himself
but the way that the actor talks about
the character he seems relatively
authentic but he has just this way about
him so I don't know if there's any kind
of religious aspect to this season or
some cult that Amy Bendix is running
from but the way Punisher then starts
talking about jigsaw like my friend
betrayed me makes it sound like she's
running from a metaphorical family or
just like a really bad group of people
that she belonged to and was trying to
escape from or she saw something that's
really incriminated and then took off
and that's why they're chasing her down
love the fight choreography that we see
obviously that's a big part of the
series is there are a couple reasons why
you watch The Punisher character he's
really compelling on the page as a comic
book character Jon Bernthal is fantastic
in his performance but also the amazing
fight choreography and the intricate use
of really hardcore weapons they're like
more hardcore bloody Bourne fights like
so he improvises a lot of situations
here like when he gets laid out by
jigsaws little band here then gets up
off the ground and takes them all down
this actress that they have here is
actually from 13 reasons why I've never
seen any of her other stuff so we'll
just see what she feels like when she's
with Jon Bernthal for the most part all
the people that survived season 1 are
coming back and obviously they're a
couple of new characters like Amy Bendix
the Jon Pilgrim character and even
though we don't get a lot of scenes with
her in the trailer for IANA Lima from
the Supergirl TV show is actually
playing the therapist this helping
jigsaw put the puzzle pieces of his
memory back together when he finally
remembers who Frank Castle is in why he
wants to take him down so bad they do
this really cool transition in the
trailer where Amy Bendix is telling him
about the people she's trying to get
away from and he says you know my friend
betrayed me and then they move to the
jigsaw part of the trailer they show you
that scene from their final fight at the
end of season one then they start the
jigsaw voice over and if you notice
benbarnes accent has changed it's way
thicker than it was in season one he
said that that's because of the trauma
that he experienced so that's his
natural accent when he grew up but
because you know he was kind of a pretty
boy he was trying to put on a lot of
airs and be more high-class he sort of
got rid of that as he grew up and became
part of the military so as he actually
becomes the actual jigsaw comic book
character he sort of strips away a lot
of that veneer that was on top that you
saw during season one the way they talk
about the characters is that he doesn't
completely remember everything that's
happened to him his memory like he says
is a jigsaw that's what he's going to
therapy for there was a promo they
released a little while ago of some of
his therapy sessions where the mask he's
wearing has not been colored to look
like the jigsaw mask that you see later
in some of these trailers so maybe
there's like a little bit at the
beginning of the season before he puts
things together but the Jon Pilgrim
character approaches him and it seems
like it's pretty early in the season
like we should work together because I'm
after Frank Castle and the girl you want
to get Frank Castle so let's combine
forces and you get all that shots of the
big band that he puts together and then
wearing their jigsaw mass although it
looks a little bit like some crazy Lucha
Libre PI Club I would call it a plus
that they're not slow-burning a lot of
this jigsaw development like he's not
gonna be all season for him to finally
figure out that Frank Castle is The
Punisher because they literally call him
out in this first meeting that they have
you get some more footage with Dinah
Madani who seems like she's
hallucinating jigsaw like this shot here
with him in the
always seems like it's just her just
freaking out because of the trauma of
what happened to her last season she
stopped pursuing Punisher because he
wasn't the real villain even though
technically he was doing a lot of
illegal stuff worked with him to take
down jigsaw and it seems like they start
out on that foot at the beginning of
season 2 whenever he comes back to New
York City because even though it seems
like she's kind of going crazy I think
she's gonna be relatively stable in that
she'll still be a homeland security
agent but she'll be working with
Punisher on the DL in a more official
capacity than she was during season 1 so
we don't know a whole lot about what
happens with jigsaw like how he goes
from being under armed guard like you
seem in the jigsaw mask with these
police people guarding his hospital bed
to him out on the streets underground
putting this small army of thugs
together
so really prediction a lot of this
footage is from the first couple of
episodes but this shot of him with a
giant automatic weapon in broad daylight
in New York City just firing on all
these cop cards that actually seems like
it's from a later in the season I don't
know what kind of weapon this is but
like you see Punisher put the punisher
vest on like you need to let me be who
I'm supposed to be
that's him fully embracing the
comic-book Punisher persona and then
going after him in broad daylight
because he's not wearing any kind of
mask he's literally running through the
streets he's still a wanted vigilante
and there was actually a promo a little
while ago of him burning a presidential
pardon that he got based on the stuff
that he did during daredevil season 2 in
Punisher season 1 part of the terms of
that were that he would not continue to
be the Punisher so him burning it is
sort of his call to action like okay I
can't not be the Punisher that's who I'm
meant to be as far as I know the only
big crossover character from daredevil
is going to be Karen Paige it's just a
continuation of her arc with Frank
Castle during season 1 they didn't
specify whether or not this picks up
after the events of daredevil season 3
I'm assuming that it does I don't know
if they're going to address what
happened to Matt like see you later red
I don't know if they're gonna reference
that during any of their conversations
but like we said this is probably gonna
be the final season of The Punisher I
don't know if they wrote it that way
hopefully the actual finale is a
conclusive satisfying ending to the
character but I think part of the idea
of superheroes like this is that they
always sort of try to end on a moment
that gives you an idea for what they're
going to be doing even if you don't get
more see
like we know after the end of daredevil
season 3 what those characters are going
to be doing next even though we probably
won't ever actually see them form that
new law firm and him put the daredevil
costume back on but what'll happen is is
for punisher season - I'll do my
non-spoilery review then I'll do my
Easter Egg videos and stuff like that if
I hear anything more about what's
happening with Netflix TV shows and the
Disney Plus streaming service I'll be
sure to add it to those videos but let
me know in the comments what you guys
are most hyped up about and I will be
working on more Marvel videos today
there's a whole bunch of stuff that just
happens so I'll try to get through it as
fast as possible
Avengers end game more Captain Marvel
stuff there's even more Game of Thrones
stuff happening - so why you wait for
everything click here to rewatch that
last really big Captain Marvel trailer
and click here for my new avengers
endgame video listen to Kevin Feige talk
about some really cool new details thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight